- These are the ones that like each other
or don't like each other.
- Hey guys, it's Kylie
and Jordan and we're here
answering some of your fan
questions with puppies.
- The show's pretty much
a long SnapChat story.
It's just really a different side of us,
more personal side and I'm just excited
for people to see that.
- Honestly, I can't even think
with this cuteness going on.
- Me and Jordan met
through mutual friends.
- One day I got a phone call from one
of my friends and they were like, yeah,
come over to Kylie's house.
We all wanna hang out.
I'm like.
- And, she put her name in my phone
and we just got closer and closer
throughout the years and realized
all we need is each other and
now we are our only friends.
Cute.
I don't know.
We used to Segway
everywhere, I mean everywhere
when we didn't have our
license, like we would
Segway outside the
community to like, miles
and miles to the mall.
Probably turning 21.
I feel like that's fun.
You know, I never had a drink before
so I just wanna know what it's like.
I'm gonna say Kim.
I feel like I go to different sisters
for different problems and right now
me and Kim have just been relating a lot
and talking.
Honestly, it changes
every day, so tomorrow
it'll probably be somebody new, but Kim
right now is my fav.
- I think Kendall would be mad
at me if I didn't say Kendall
so I'm gonna go with Kendall.
- What do you think?
Amusement park.
- Get a puppy.
- Really.
Everything I can't do so I would love
to just go have lunch and maybe shop.
This is not okay 'cause you know
how I am with puppies.
- Should we take all of them?
- Like, I really am gonna
go get a puppy right now.
- Bill Nye.
The science guy.
- I love Bill Nye, the
science guy for real.
He is sexy, let me tell you.
- Very daddyim, if you're into it.
- But, if I had to say someone else
probably it's only Bill Nye.
We tried to take a picture with him once.
- I saw him walking down the street and.
- He said no.
I totally understand when you just
wanna say no, but like,
we were really upset.
Kendall's killing it,
Bella Hadid is killing it,
Kim, just pretty much like
my friends and family.
- For me, I just, I find
style inspo from like
random things, like people
walking down the street
or anyone on Instagram where
I'm like, oh they're cool.
I wanna wear my thing like this, too.
Or, I wouldn't say there's one
person in particular for me.
- I literally read crazy things about me
like all day every day, so I can't really
think of anything
specifically, but probably
just that like, I'm getting
married all the time
or I don't know, just
I read too many things.
I can't keep track.
This isn't fair.
- They like this dress.
They really like my dress.
They think it's very cushy and cozy.
Lash extensions.
- Lash extensions.
- And moisturizer, I
cannot live without lotion.
- I can't live without lipstick.
If I forget the lipstick
at home it's the one thing
I will turn around.
Sorry, I know you wanna leave,
but you make so much noise.
I would always overline
my lips when I was like 16
and all my fans would
be like, what color are
you wearing?
That's all my comment section would say.
Like, what lipstick color are you wearing?
So, I just thought why not make my own.
Reality shows, I really only watch
Keeping Up or Life With Kylie
has kept me entertained.
I do binge watch a lot of other shows
like Handmaid's Tale.
I'm always trying to find new shows.
I really try hard to take
my makeup completely off,
like I need to get every inch of my face.
I need to clean my lashes.
I put on sunscreen every morning.
I can't wear a lot of moisturizer
because it breaks my
face out, unfortunately.
- I don't know what people think about us
'cause I tend to not look at it.
- Just a lot.
I feel like people have
it all wrong sometimes.
- I think they have
almost everything wrong.
- Everything.
- Except for your love of cosmetics.
- It was pretty deep, but
there wasn't a lotta waves
and Kim kind of threw a
tantrum like, immediately
when she found out that she lost it.
And I was like, no, this is fine.
I went under there and it was salt water
so it kinda hurt to
open my eyes, but I just
opened my eyes and looked around and I saw
something shining, swam
all the way down there,
it was like 10 feet,
picked it up and it was
the shining diamond.
I literally found it in two minutes.
- I think you have a future career.
- Then, I was, she was like, I don't have
my backing, but it's fine.
I can always get that.
I was like, I'm just gonna look.
So, I went back down there
and found the backing.
I found the earring backing.
She was like, you are just.
- Future career, I'm telling you.
- Diamond finder.
- Dive team.
- This was one of the best interviews.
I hope we weren't too
distracted, but thanks
for stickin' through it.
- I was, see I'm too distracted.
Alright, it's been real and now.
You've been plotting to get him to switch.
- Don't fall.
- All the puppies love me.
- You just remind me of this little puppy
I wanted in the pet store one time.